planes flying over Michigan close to
Lake Huron after the fourth high
altitude object was shot down in just
eight days the Pentagon says it's
unprecedented and Beyond its size and
altitude little is known about the
latest octagonal object down by U.S jet
officials say it posed no security
threats but they aren't ruling out
anything
have you ruled out aliens or
extraterrestrial terrestrials and if so
why I'll let the Intel community and the
counterintelligence community figured
that out I haven't ruled out anything at
this point we continue to assess every
threat or Potential Threat unknown that
approaches North America with an attempt
to identify
in January a giant Chinese balloon
drifted for days over American and
Canadian airspace before it was shot
down earlier this month of the South
Carolina coast
U.S officials called it a surveillance
object but China insisted it was
conducting weather research
since then three unidentified objects
have been downed but only the first has
been attributed to Beijing it's been
publicly reported that the Chinese have
had a very robust system of utilizing
balloons for surveillance in The
Sovereign airspace of other countries
reportedly the Chinese have violated the
airspace of over 40 countries worldwide
utilizing this system of surveillance
balloon the incidents have further
strained ties between Washington and
Beijing with Secretary of State Anthony
blinken calling off a visit meant to
ease relations
and it's prompted questions about the
extent of China's surveillance in the
United States
[Music]